I think it's more than just putting on
the costume I think it's your love for
it coming out I think it's also
sometimes embodying the character like I
know when I put on this costume
I feel really sexy you and I wear armor
it's an idea of like empowerment because
you get to you get to feel really you to
be a different person for the day so if
you're kind of a shy person you get to
be someone who's not that shy and people
forgive you because it's the character
I've always thought geek culture comic
culture they've always had the idea
accepting everyone for who they are
you know superpowers being different and
that idea kind of struck a chord with
everyone here on any sort of level
whether it be character based or
personality wise you know it lets you be
yourself truly there's some people who
just love the attention some people who
love to just put in the time and effort
and then get to show it off I'm a
narcissist so I enjoy the attention
people like out of their box it lets
people be whatever superhero or villain
I thought it would be funny everybody
goes for it usually traditionally the
Super Mario characters I thought like
what let's go some a little bit
different no one's ever seen fire Mario
ever that's a lot of light it balls and
it's like let's go even further let's go
do a hipster twist I really love cross
play I love when people do like femme
versions of anything sometimes it's just
fun to kind of play around with this
idea of gender and like making it a
gender that suits you with technology
catching up people have personal skills
that are just incredible basic
theatrical fabrication now is possible
for someone to do at home so yes you see
incredible designs for me it's like 100%
artful not to make any money off of this
exactly you pour more into it than you
receive back well the only way you
receive back is by gratitude of people
around you they take pictures and it
goes all over the web so that's the only
gratitude I guess everyone loves to see
these characters especially the kids you
know you see their eyes light up because
they see their superhero right in front
of them makes it all worth it